david le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer air
souhaite que les écoles restent ouvertes
même en cas de confinement est ce qu'on
peut parler de climat de défiance des
enseignants envers leur ministre de
tutelle
un climat de défiance qui prend tout son
sens et effectivement puisque nous
sommes loin du ministère de l'éducation
nationale point final de cette
manifestation est de ce rassemblement à
l'initiative de plusieurs syndicats
l'objectif c'est évidemment la
revalorisation salariale
les 400 millions d'euros promis par jean
michel blanquer en septembre est visible
dès ce mois de janvier sur la fiche de
fait sont jugés insuffisants par les
organisations syndicales à l'initiative
de ce rassemblement
autre point de crispation le contexte
sanitaire évidemment la crise sanitaire
qui n'a fait que creuser les inégalités
entre les unités scolaires entre les
élèves et les étudiants les étudiants
qui sont les principaux concernés par
cette crise sanitaire et qui était
fortement présent dans ce cortège
écouter on voit les facs qui sont fermés
depuis novembre alors que les étudiants
qui sont isolés chez eux je parle même
pas la détresse des taux de suicide
alors que depuis des mois et des mois il
ya les syndicats je pense au snes sup
mais aussi à l'unef qui réclament tout
simplement de l'argent dans les
universités qui disent qu'on pourrait
ouvrir les facs tenir des cours avec le
respect total des gestes barrières pour
que l'ensemble des étudiants et des
bonnes conditions d'études
pour ça il faudrait un milliard un
milliard cinq ce qui est rien par
rapport aux 500 milliards qui ont été
données par le gouvernement aux grandes
entreprises depuis le début de la crise
une génération sacrifiée voilà ce que
dénonce également les professeurs et
enseignants au sein de cette
manifestation dans le viseur également
le grenelle de l'éducation évidemment
plusieurs politiques au sein des
manifestants étaient présents dans le
cortège afin de dénoncer le manque
d'anticipation mais aussi elle le manque
de moyens promis à l'éducation nationale
par le gouvernement en place le
gouvernement souhaite absolument que les
parents aillent au boulot donc il faut
laisser les écoles ouvertes ans est le
seul objectif
mais il n'y a aucun moyen donner aux
enseignants pour satisfaire les
contraintes sanitaires et permettent de
recevoir les élèves dans des conditions
décentes
je parle même pas de l'université où là
c'est une catastrophe absolue pour des
raisons politiques budgétaires les facs
sont fermés ça va faire un nom il ya une
souffrance psychologique des étudiants
qui est énorme qui n'est pas comprise
qui n'est pas soigné par par le
gouvernement et ce gouvernement est en
train de tourner le dos à la jeunesse
pour un pays comme le nôtre c'est
catastrophique
quand on comprend plus la jeunesse c'est
qu'on n'a plus rien à faire au
gouvernement
quand on voit que pendant la crise en
pleine pandémie en 2020 les
milliardaires français ont engrangé 175
milliards de plus c'est à dire deux fois
le budget de l'hôpital public comme l'a
révélé le rapport de l'oms of fame
je pense qu'on a les moyens dans ce pays
d'assurer que nos services publics
auxquels les français tiennent
particulièrement comme c'est le cas de
l'éducation et les moyens de fonctionner
et les moyens de fonctionner sans
prendre de risque ni pour les élèves ni
pour les professeurs dont la période de
pandémie en tout cas à ce rassemblement
s'est déroulé dans le calme encadrés par
un important dispositif de sécurité
encore une fois et qui s'est attaché non
loin de du ministère de l'éducation
nationale afin de protester et de leur
réclamer plus de moyens pour l'éducation
nationale
merci david khalifa en direct du cortège
parisien donc